[Music]
[Music]
let's do this good morning [ __ ]
morning welcome to the Church of what's
[ __ ] happening now Joey D is
here Lisa at co-host was going on people
to a beautiful [ __ ] day the
line to be alive let's mark this [ __ ]
joint and get the Holy Smoke cooking in
this [ __ ] good over here at 5:30
already at this nothing I opened up this
morning with a little [ __ ] Black
Sabbath Sabbath bloody Sabbath for you
guys let me tell you something when I
was in my Downey's times I started
listening at Black Sabbath when I was
like in the eighth grade when I was
going through all my [ __ ] Sabbath
[ __ ] saved me especially salmon but
put that let me explain something this
album came out at pumping 73 Sabbath
bloody Sabbath the front cover the front
covers dumps around and some [ __ ] guy
that's dying when you turn the cover
around instead of that for those family
members it's the [ __ ] devil's
fighting for his [ __ ] soul Jesus is
right in Satan
it's a beautiful cover it's got killing
yourself to live on they're looking for
today Sabbath bloody [ __ ] Sabbath
killing yourself to live tremendous
[ __ ] Jam but Sabbath bloody Sabbath
some of my black sadboys to happen when
I was 15 after my mother died I listened
to it let me taste him my mind was going
[ __ ] fine kill at least have a bloody
[ __ ] here you go from the
beginning mate from the beginning
doesn't that [ __ ] guitar
here you go
[Music]
you're [ __ ] up with this music
already leaked [ __ ] the same you
didn't play with me later
oh yeah a little salmon early you know
what Sabbath does it cleans off the
[ __ ] spirit too bad Sperry as I call
him the SPD throws malos a lot of people
mad at me about mrs. Obama common I met
last night listen I loved mrs. Obama
don't disrespectful let me tell you
something I said you know I was gonna
eat a black little monkey she's
tremendous mrs. Obama so I'm sorry if
you got offended but he had forgot to
tell you no no they will hate a black
little monkey I eat that black little
[ __ ] muffler - it probably smells
like health you understand me so
beautifully with Sabbath bloody Sabbath
kicked that [ __ ]
and still playing
we will peel in the bad spirits at the
Holy Smoke here take a hit you [ __ ]
that's a boy [ __ ] we're spreading
it man this shows about getting up being
the [ __ ] good mood
people always hit me back Joey what the
[ __ ] he in a bad mood about or what even
good mood about I turn the music up
we're talking them good [ __ ] mood in
the morning there's got a picture of
these guys he I grew up with it's Dom
express yeah Gavin ray go and Anthony
[ __ ] balls and they're dead and they
died when we were young this is the
first thing I look at in the morning get
in the [ __ ] good mood cuz they're not
here so I gotta do what the [ __ ] they're
not doing so I gotta cover this print
today that's the mentality of the Church
of what's happening at you think enjoy
what the [ __ ] you glasses my glasses I
don't want to be like one of those black
basketball players you see these
[ __ ] right it all started about
twenty years ago like all these [ __ ]
actors once they get a little older they
start wearing glasses and I could see
the husband wife saying you look so
sophisticated and so smart where the
[ __ ] glasses so they started with
that [ __ ] now I got Kobe I got the
guy in [ __ ] Miami
everybody's wearing [ __ ] Poindexter
glasses for $9,000 to look more
intelligent get it together [ __ ]
you're a basketball player not a
scientist all right the [ __ ] with a
little Halloween costume ain't gonna
work [ __ ] on these [ __ ] early
because if not they think I'm over here
[ __ ] around did you work out
yesterday only yeah I did I would you do
I was supposed to have a training
session but a woman apparently has too
many trainers so I went over to the gym
and my complex and I'm just starting out
guys I don't know if anyone else is
starting out working out you haven't
worked out I wrestled all throughout
high school and I probably haven't
worked out since I stopped since
wrestling season stop my senior year
that's probably like six or seven years
so I'm starting out fresh and I'm just
undoing the stationary bike for like
half an hour and I can do the elliptical
for about 10 15 and then I when I pass
out but oh you [ __ ] me to get the
party started what you want to do is the
fat guys get the [ __ ] blood going
that's what I had to do I mean they
threw me out of why the first time I
walked in there really the [ __ ]
little trainer cuz you sign up for the Y
and Holly wouldn't you go down there and
then give me like an evaluation to see
what the [ __ ] you're at I thought I was
still like in high school I wasn't like
seven eight years I was right after the
longest shot
I thought I was stolen I just gotta do a
thousand Jumpman Jackson should he put
me on the treadmill to start and put
like 1.5 let me tell you something my
friend at the 4-minute mark I tapped out
he was a little cute little gay guy goes
listen dawg
I love you to death but don't come back
here till you stop smoking cigarettes do
you start getting it together you can't
even walk on the treadmill so that's why
[ __ ] started yeah you know I started
at 4 [ __ ] 15 where you walk a half a
block and your joints hurt your knees
hurt your feet so I put the whole
training session in my head I knew by
going to the [ __ ] Y that they have a
heated pool so I just started going to
the heated pool and I would run back and
forth and I would swim but I would swim
15 minutes 20 minutes then I got cocky
and I held the slept one night and I
jumped into the Olympic pool because it
bold I used to be part of the Masters
Swimming program what's that the
Masterson program is where you go at
6:00 in the morning at 6:00 at night and
the lady's name was Jane and she would
just work you like a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] slave in the water and she was
before I got locked up in prison there
was a UPS guy at the Hertz where I
worked at and he was in great shape I
said how'd you get in that [ __ ] and
shaped me because I started going to the
master swimming program [ __ ] volumes
already gets too low these [ __ ]
people always say it's too low but
company and you were getting your mother
was all in the other room like when you
listen to Richard Pryor so ah you go at
6:00 in the [ __ ] morning in Boulder
Colorado in the dead of the [ __ ]
winter and the pool would be outside and
they'd be surrounded by snow where they
shoveled
and you'd have to [ __ ] and dress
yourself and a little hot and [ __ ]
run out and jump in a pool you have to
do two of those a day a day three times
a [ __ ] week and she would train you
for a little triathlon
my triathlons the double ones the ones
where you swim and jump up and down for
a half hour without really like all free
ride your bike that's a triathlon and
moose tree so I always liked [ __ ]
sweater not to mention I'm CUBAN you
know you know me I strap around the
[ __ ] I was a young man like a savage
[ __ ] oh Jesus so uh I went back
and I jumped into your limpid pool and
that's what I almost drowned
I was drama that's a scary story man I
don't know if people have heard it you
want song together
[ __ ] no I almost drowned I went to the Y
jump the [ __ ] in the pool and you know
what when you go into a training pool
it's heated but when you go into an
irregular
it's not [ __ ] people that's that's
it's a difference dirty agree so first
thing you'd it surrounds your lungs you
can't [ __ ] breathe Here I am in the
middle of a pool my fat legs were just
[ __ ] moving I wasn't going away
though I get spinning around like a
mother buck up swimming stuff I mean I
used to swim my store I mean I was never
really in shape when I wrestled but I
was more in shape and you went around
the track and I play football you run
around the thing and won against women
are two different things swimming is
tough especially when you're hard to see
if it really shows you when you're out
of shape like wow I am out of shape but
it gets you in the best shape the
problem and exercise doesn't go with you
the rest of the day like when you run
for a half hour 6:00 in the morning that
raises your metabolism that goes of you
you release sweat when you go on the
pool it burns the most calories per
minute okay but when you get out of the
pool you don't take it with you as much
it doesn't burn like throughout the
whole [ __ ] day around which women a
lot of people don't know that
okay I'm saying so I worked out
yesterday had a good time I went over
there I got in the treadmill I hit the
bag for half hour on the treadmill and
ran that did to Mike Dolce two minutes
on and a half and not 30 minutes thirty
seconds of running and I got on the bike
to close it out look at that shirt
[ __ ] super swelling right next day I
might eat some sushi and like I did
going on three okay it's rough man I
mean it's uh there's not much there's
not much going out I mean I'm working on
a TV show and everything that's gonna be
in productions in production and I felt
bad for you guys I mean there's not that
much shooting like I don't give a [ __ ]
about that we're always doing suddenly
what the [ __ ] did that the show is about
getting up in the [ __ ] morning and go
on they're not they're tackling the [ __ ]
everything you just got to make it
happen yeah there's always action up
tail you got to just get up you got to
get up with the [ __ ] towel you've
seen training places that's great
brothers at the end of the floor
Mortimer's on the floor dying because
your brother's dying [ __ ] them we got to
do what the [ __ ] we do here you're
following me so don't worry about the
[ __ ] Weight Watchers or whatever the
big topical I've been hearing about
lately he's just all de blanco' let's
break it down I've never been [ __ ]
impression to cocaine Cowboys and I'll
tell you why because they're talking
about it in 1979 you know I would go to
Miami in 1970 as a kid my mother
baptized a girl down there and I would
go down there and spend time with them
in the summer I loved them Rodolfo and
Vivian Vivian was a schoolteacher with
Dafa was a construction mobile he
going till we built all that [ __ ] the
Falls in Miami that's the north loss
always said eyes they say Southwest one
hundred thousand and one hundred and
thirty that was seven and eight then I
go down and we clear bushes me and the
Sun and the daughters and we do the
whole thing now at night the three kids
would go to sleep and that would hang
out with Rodolfo so Rodolfo knew my
father I mean he grew up in my father
and he always assumed that I knew what
my father did so when I would go down
that would stay with down from the
middle of night he go come on let's take
a ride and we go to walk he thought
lucky that Miami is a little [ __ ]
it's a gas station that doesn't sell gas
if they just sell beer milk and bread
okay and cigarettes and you'd go there
late night but it's the coldest [ __ ]
beer you'd ever had and we drive I
thought he thought he'd get in the
[ __ ] he get me a soda
but he's let me drink out it was cold
Budweiser that was like a big tree for
me love go to his boat and we got on the
boat we'd go out like ten [ __ ] miles
out and he'd pick up bales a weed
business at ease and then we drive him
back in like nothing it was like
stealing they would flown into this
thing he knew the people and that's what
he did for a limit you know and I
remember going down it without when you
watch cuz Giselle the documentary
talking about how she ran [ __ ] in Miami
in 79 by the [ __ ] 79 is when I started
doing blow what happened in 79 also this
wall went down so never happened 79 was
Mario Leto's came in those [ __ ]
Cuba's they started killing 130,000
Cubans for that without a model in jails
in 1979 130,000 100,000 of them were
[ __ ] key are in jail and these were
you know like for smacking their wife or
something these mother [ __ ] were no
more oh this [ __ ] jail with you
walking around half naked there's a hole
in the middle of the [ __ ] floor
and you gotta go pee and [ __ ] in that
[ __ ] home people tacky and take in
the [ __ ] whole [ __ ] the ass [ __ ]
so these were the type of criminals that
came over this is a type of crime you
know when he and Scarface they show the
ham and call the Eibach woz and these
people were [ __ ] nuts for example my
my stepfather's name is later walked
oriental which means four winds and he
had three brothers two of them came from
Cuba at that time and four of his
nephews or three of his nephews within
the first year four other three out of
four nephews were dead and they shot his
both both his brothers Jesus because
they didn't know anything else they came
hang on to the [ __ ] cocaine business
and by that time it became Barracuda
ville that's where her claim to fame was
that she shot now let me explain
something to you I watched the first
documentary and I bought into it and
whatnot and then the second one was just
a waste of my [ __ ] time but it's
funny because the other night when it
happened I read it in the afternoon and
without not thinking nothing of it and
then went out and Rogan called me that
night he goes he he they shot his alibi
go [ __ ] and we started laughing and
saying you know what the lady killed or
supposedly killed all these [ __ ]
people - a year old kid you know what
she was walking around knowing it was
coming if you you know one of the
reasons why I got out of crime was one
thing you never want something not gonna
your door when you're 50 [ __ ] years
old you know whatever you do at 20 is
great you don't want to do time and
[ __ ] 15 above you don't want to die in
a [ __ ] can that's an item that's a
bad [ __ ] life what is that result
that gives Elva a [ __ ] so you
don't want to end up in that was the
biggest deterrent I had was seeing my
uncle Miami go to jail it 50 and you
know when he went to jail he was a
millionaire and next thing you know he's
got to move into an apartment Lana
because the federal penitentiaries in
Atlanta even though he was rockin in
Miami he got to move to Atlanta and put
his kids in a two-bedroom apartment
three [ __ ] kids I see what it does to
you and I see what it does to your
family but the worst thing is that you
don't want to die in the can and that's
the worst thing about Karma man that way
you're walking around when you do
something like there's the people in
front in front of my house here that
Park and then go to work instead of
parking for free parking they parked
back here cuz they don't want to do this
thicker or some [ __ ] and they parked in
front of my house every [ __ ] day I
wake up and I see the same cars and I'm
gonna go over to stick a nail in front
of him I flattened their [ __ ] tie or
a scratch that door you know my stepdad
was a fanatic about the spot in front of
his [ __ ] house oh yeah his on his
mind they belonged to him was it in New
York it was in Jersey not Bergen New
Jersey and he would sit there all [ __ ]
night watching the spot with somebody
who parking it he'd go out then flatten
his [ __ ] tires I got to the point
where nobody would parking on the
[ __ ] block because they know that
tires would be [ __ ] flat what do you
look at the [ __ ] thing for him
talking to you I'm sorry No
yeah I sit out there sometimes I'm like
you know what I'm gonna flatten this
guy's tired today one good thing about
getting cat [ __ ] and putting it on a
door handle and you know at forty nine I
know one thing if I do that I'm gonna
walk around I got something coming to me
oh yeah I never want something coming to
me that's the problem with [ __ ] karma
so Gisela whatever rest in peace but
dirty [ __ ] you knew you had a comment
you got this sling and blow getting your
[ __ ] little black [ __ ] sucker come
on me and [ __ ] suck they killed in
front of a daughter-in-laws motorcycle
Chara in the hair [ __ ] new jack city
style you don't say that's not I had a
question I was thinking I read that
article and I was thing about it the
other day do you know of anybody who's
like has been a drug dealer or doing
that stuff for their entire life life
and actually gets away with it and like
doesn't go to jail end up dead or other
people who can do that for like a
lifetime are they ever a lot of people
do it for like fun but there's never you
always pay somewhere okay
you're always gonna pay somewhere
somewhere you gotta pay for your [ __ ]
sense so you might rock'n'roll and make
some money but you might have other
heartaches that are associated with that
and you know you know what it's kind of
my landscape made a bunch of money but
he had a [ __ ] son and his wife
always blamed that really on the
[ __ ] say you know what he had done
and I shouldn't say [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] at home or whatever I don't
[ __ ] know
but they she always blamed on that you
gotta come always remember that the
Church of what's happening now let's
play some [ __ ] musically what I need
a move for it today all right you wanna
play more Black Sabbath or do you want
to play something else I don't know I'm
in the mood for some exotic what do you
[ __ ] think we like that we've got a
little bit of rap but not really or any
country country that's not [ __ ] bad
you know about I love I like this
what the the [ __ ] chicken the guy the
lady out the Belem I like those [ __ ]
through this savages don't forget mr.
T's calling today my high school
teachers calling in about 20 minutes
mr. T's a very interesting guy I love
this guy and I've spoken to him I keep
in touch with him he was my teacher from
freshman year to senior year in high
school
and pretty much after that he kept me
out of he kept me from [ __ ] taking a
swan dive as he would call it you know
Joey I hear through the [ __ ] ranks
you thinking of taking a swan dive it
ain't worth it so I didn't see him from
the time I graduated maybe two and in 84
I seen him on a street corner he pulled
up next to me was you looking like
[ __ ] multiple Van Damme warmed over
look at you you filthy [ __ ] Savage
well it was bad [ __ ] so uh he
said you know you gotta get your life
together you can't keep hanging out on
corners and the next thing you [ __ ]
know I had a leaf I had to leave in love
Bergen New Year's Eve 1984 New Year's
Eve 84 because I fronted a half ounce of
blow so I figured that front that I
found to blow keep the pocket money and
start a new life I called him about 6:00
in the morning he picked me up and took
me to crash killed New Jersey about 15
miles away and he took me to a few AAA
meetings and he believed in me you know
a good job in the city and I got a job
at a liquor store and I kept [ __ ]
doing my thing so after two months one
day goes I got a call from the cops do
me a favor don't come back to you pull
up with a [ __ ] Cadillac that ends now
I went to Rascals one time I called him
i lying got no Cadillac but I'm getting
on stage do you want to come and we and
that was about 15 years ago we've been
tight and whenever he sees me on TV
calls me and he's my high school teacher
Wow
mr. t and I love him to death and this
is the reason I do this [ __ ] you know to
make people like that proud they want to
win for me so I'm trying to go on a
[ __ ] limb for that being said now
looking back into those times when you
were when most people would help you out
any we're still doing primer still doing
drugs did you feel bad doing that you
just couldn't stop where you just didn't
you know I think of a [ __ ] why do I give
a [ __ ] you're doing your thing dog when
you do your thing you commit you don't
[ __ ] look back week when you got to
pull out a [ __ ] gun and so what are
you gonna do I mean you know you you're
caught up in different things in your
life you know I made mistakes like
everybody [ __ ] else some women suck 50
cops you know I tried to roll the [ __ ]
what are you gonna [ __ ] it happens
sometimes in your life
but I'm here to tell ya I wasn't not
happy about it now I'm gonna have a
child I don't want the [ __ ] kid to
know but what are you gonna do the kid's
gonna know and you live with it you
stick with your decisions as things we
do when you ain't got a [ __ ] gun we
about a little [ __ ] Allison change
this morning down in a hole direct from
the from dog murky waters are the
underworld where there's H this [ __ ]
everything understand me and if you find
a live one do it but just go off at dirt
just to get people in the [ __ ] mood
today because this shows about getting
up it's 6:00 in the [ __ ] morning we
think I'm doing up here I'm here for my
[ __ ] health all right when I was a
kid and I get up there beat the news the
news and Jack my land
don't [ __ ] sit ups in a body suit
like Bruce Lee without the [ __ ]
stripe here you got a bunch of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] got 800 channels and then
you got mad flavor you guys what what
Allison changed on your place down
enough [ __ ] hole okay
great [ __ ] album dirt one of my
all-time favorites I mean let me tell
you something man I was down and out
with music after the 80s I was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and when all that stuff came
out of Seattle I was never so [ __ ]
happy I like that [ __ ] so much
I made a girl move to [ __ ]
Seattle that's how much I liked that
Soundgarden Alice in Chains I mean all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] Pearl Jam it was just
a beautiful time to be up there and I
was very fortunate too bad I was on
probation the whole [ __ ] time what
are you gonna do what are you looking
for a [ __ ] crystal ball over there
loading loading what do you got AT&T
versus for what are they [ __ ] loading
these [ __ ] they charge you for
[ __ ] everything it's gonna be the
speed of light and then nothing [ __ ]
happens they're the biggest [ __ ] rip
balls without a gun 18 audience sprint I
love them to death I love my [ __ ]
sprint phone I don't like this is
falling uh no no I'm saying money oh
there's a [ __ ] we don't do that Lee
cause you throw me off okay when you
move your head and you tell me I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on you're in
the middle of dropping [ __ ] knowledge
what are you doing look who's coming
[ __ ] here where the restroom
Terry Clark
what happened give me a Papa there's
great great they're all [ __ ] here who
you kiddin all my little cats I hear
these types of my pregnant wife is here
I got weed all over my [ __ ] what's
happening guys come on you wanna say
hello sleeping to make
my little man skinny bombelli
say hello [ __ ] ii say hello that's right
say hello say hello go ahead speak until
the mic [ __ ] my boy is [ __ ] see we
got a third co-host is my old boy here I
got some [ __ ] fat greens catnip bugs
is the real [ __ ] deal people if you
got cats and you love your cats don't
[ __ ] around what I'm saying don't smoke
the buds all look at that since they
look like [ __ ] medical marijuana bugs
like any kind of but look at this [ __ ]
and your cat goes [ __ ] mine look at
Harry Wong you know I love my [ __ ]
cats I love animals if you got a dog if
you got a [ __ ] cat go hug that
[ __ ] right now namaste pops up
cause it's a beautiful day to be alive
right there part of those nuts watch
those [ __ ] nuts those more leave
what's up with the [ __ ] there I'm
over here sweating like that [ __ ] it I
smoked it myself and this reefer brought
to you today by no whole cc I don't even
know what the [ __ ] it is like Superman
bud I got my [ __ ] vape over here just
in case there's an earthquake and I
can't fly my lighter
mm-hmm like a doctor little something
for Obama milk rob me put this in your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
does that [ __ ] anti marijuana
oh yeah so for you [ __ ]
Republicans that have vote for that
[ __ ] Herman Munster look at
[ __ ] just remember he goes into
office we're really gonna get down here
there's gonna be no reef and then uh
'then but i don't give a [ __ ] well guess
I got the paper pen and worst case
scenario you know me I've smoked these
[ __ ] cat buds out all these from
[ __ ] Amazon go to Amazon pet greens
catnip buds I love this [ __ ] on my cat
they get used to it though now see they
get their resistance like we everyone so
while you're paying attention for the
phone this [ __ ] on my call
it's on
he might call him a couple minutes
that's how lucky we are so I still keep
in touch with my high school teachers
[ __ ] of supper we're gonna have to get
Barone's a call if anyone wants the
documentary Barone was on the guy with
the red shirt in the blue background
he's great that's a good [ __ ] idea
I'm elected that the stripper core I
called her this morning she ain't
[ __ ] answer and I wanted to see what
her deal was wait that [ __ ] freak up
and talk about hand jobs and whatever
the [ __ ] she does who's this
[ __ ] send an email it's early
about travel they say in this [ __ ]
about travel calm there's a [ __ ] if you
keep sending me emails after a year I
don't get back to you why you sending me
what are you wasting your time you think
I'm gonna change my [ __ ] mind about
your product now I got Boston Market
sending [ __ ] emails you get their
emails no come on
Boston Market yelling listen man boy
when you're a fat [ __ ] Boston markets
got great turkey ha ha ha we gonna get a
little slice of [ __ ] turkey with a
little stuffing you know your double
size of meat get extra protein you put
that trip to [ __ ] the norm in your
system you go home and take a nap you
smoked a [ __ ] blood so it's not bad
because you're not gonna make a [ __ ]
turkey every week turkeys dry too much
lemon out that tell us stay away from it
like turkey dinner
I'll have turkey sandwich epic turkeys
Drive yeah but the problem is cuz you
ordered a turkey dinner on a [ __ ]
Wednesday by that anything's [ __ ] try
her [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right you got to
eat the turkey dinner when it's fresh on
a Sunday even oh-ho see see down the
[ __ ] quano ho see see a normal diner
which you ordered the spaghetti and find
that I'll add the [ __ ] food was they
got a great turkey on Sunday they slice
it in the mashed potatoes and blow the
[ __ ] grave ulis a pimple juice like
right head pimple juice niche hits the
[ __ ] mirror it's thick but uh he's
koala no what are you looking at me for
like I'm on probation [ __ ]
everybody's everybody everybody that you
saw last night listen I had a lot of
break this down figure cuz people gonna
get pissed off and I don't give a [ __ ]
and here goes all right well I turned
out that Democratic convention last
night and I seen that Puerto Rican
Mexican dude in his last name is Castro
I'm more shocked myself
that was a [ __ ] weak move putting up
a [ __ ]
les Castro left function talk to people
took over a [ __ ] island and shovel up
their [ __ ] ass and it's never good I
hate Castro every day yeah Castro
convertibles I hate I hate Castro I hate
him [ __ ] it all so I got pissed off but
thank God my guy you know what I'll tell
you what I always think this election
was gonna be won by the women on this
one cuz they're [ __ ] close
I thought Obama's wife was gonna go up
playin throw up Pete I loved mrs. Obama
so don't get me wrong
oh that [ __ ] thing was brutal she
that was that that [ __ ] let's just give
me and he'd be talking about a family
and walking up the stairs and seeing her
father there's a [ __ ] all right let me
know what your husband's gonna do I
gotta sit through this [ __ ] you me
that's one of those coke Kania beans
when you want the chick the suck your
dick but you gotta let her tell a story
to get there you know I'm saying she's
telling me about a father coming home
and she'd be on the top of the stairs do
I need this buffing aggravation in my
life just like my nuts and move on with
your [ __ ] long story
ya know I can't stand this time of year
I get yelled at all the time cuz they
don't vote it all lies you gotta go
[ __ ] vote but they're all [ __ ] lies
at least you see through it I mean you
know the big question is how much does
your life change the four [ __ ] years
guess what Lee Obama didn't change my
life at least I got changed my life Joe
Rogan so you follow um same team but you
know what we're not doing bad the people
we know I'm doing bad because we live
here you know I get to travel I'm really
fortunate I get to go to Pittsburgh
where the sport bars don't [ __ ] open
unless there's a Pittsburgh pirate game
and they're in town if they're away
there's no business you know I go to
Buffalo where it's half to being on it's
half the [ __ ] business I go to
Cleveland I go to Cincinnati I go to a
lot of these cities where you look
around and go what the [ __ ] even less
than I went to Houston it wasn't booming
down there there was a lot of strip
malls that were [ __ ] open and whatnot
so you know the country is not it's not
everything that's not a lie I sweet we
good you know we see [ __ ] Jews
driving BMW and [ __ ] out of these
those [ __ ] filthy [ __ ] hypocrites
with their [ __ ] little half a
yarmulke wait till we make our [ __ ]
yarmulke line
[ __ ] you pay me that's the name of my
yarmulke line manly it's gonna be a
white yarmulke what [ __ ] you pay me I
like that just look at a [ __ ]
don't know what time it is
[ __ ] Jews driving mercedes-benz when
you told me that one time my feelings
got hurt I never really talked about it
that way those [ __ ] Momo's you go
down to town with a [ __ ] Honda what's
up baby
no it's you got to pick up the phone
eight one eight
penis you got a callback at that number
brother he's gonna switch it on no seven
seven one night yes all right brother
will be here all right stay black Mike
that's my man Freddie boom-boom
terranova my [ __ ] mentor in life
right there that's how we do it I've
been running with mr. t since 1979
freshman year I met him and I ran out in
the football field goatee am I gonna
play was freshman year he goes yes then
the sidelines of some so I was I got I
don't know cold feet I'm on the
sidelines talking to these guys and he's
like d.edge Diaz and I heard him I'm
like I'm not [ __ ] play now my
four-minute stuff I run over to him I
know yes coach and he goes where the
[ __ ] you been sit that to your ass grows
boots he is Freddy T what's happening
baby how's mrs. T doing good she's
waiting it going in and get the right
medication all right you're beautiful
Tia what I was talking when I was
telling these savages not to cut you off
was that uh you know you're my high
school teacher we became friends nobody
ever cut you you have a great reputation
because you always cracked a joke
and then in 85 and 84 you seen me
standing on the corner you pulled over
you're like look at you look like death
warmed over you need a meeting you need
a shower and then two weeks later you
put me in your home and it started this
great life of mine and then the cops
called you one day and I called you go
do me a favor don't come by until you
pull up with a Cadillac just tell them
how you changed it all brother yeah well
that's good man you did good you came a
long way from 1977 wearing uh you
sneakiest
school you were the first one not to tie
your laces because she was a lazy
bastard that's right I don't you was a
skinny lazy bag you must have weighed
about 120 pounds I mean freaking bananas
in your yard north are you but you did
good in school you weren't funny Basulto
Roger Holloway all the dogs man all the
dogs came and went a red shoes red vests
green hair everything I got use every
day to remember [ __ ] ho ho mother
hindu girl with the big feet I would say
oh yeah you would say you would say
lighten up on the [ __ ] hobos I mean
then we had your summer school we had
June summer school we would go and you
would teach history you will go this
ain't fall history history is Woodstock
Alvin Lee and you turn this on Albert
Lee till this day I listen to album
because you and I laugh every [ __ ]
time every time Alvin Lee 10 years 10
years I'm coming on what was the comment
all did you go see Santana how little
you sup myself Fillmore East played all
night they were throwing black beauties
up in the air all over the joint man we
were up for like a week it's really good
they played all night Santana I'm
staring they spunk in the beginning they
played Wow
did they really stink in the beginning
yeah yeah he would stop in every five
minutes he would stop the band stop the
band stop be pitiful like an hour and
then they got rolling and we nobody
cared I was wrecked the whole Sun was
right and Benny started playing so we
play it all night and we left out of
here like 7:00 in the morning in Omani
East Side in the village yeah it was
like great it was a great shot even had
like a warm-up before he came on I had a
band called King cruisin who had more
synthesizer ever you know I mean it was
back anything T dropping like a gallon
I'll tell you where the bet you know T
to go to school no
we cut you for number one and you made
kids who want to go to school because
you'd always make a [ __ ] comment and
since then I've had the utmost respect
for teachers because in reality you guys
raised us you know holy God you gotta
know something
you don't learn something become
everyday you learn something and that's
all that counts you learned something
you know not learn that learn [ __ ]
calmly dog cause you would you would
call attendance and get everybody up and
goof on their t-shirt look at your
[ __ ] at the head dude where'd you get
those shoes one I remember the day the
Puerto Rican kid some Puerto Rican kid
from the Spanish cafeteria stepped on
your shoes and you looked at your homies
and you said getting us killed
you said get those who could be duper
engage shoes off my feet yeah I was a
goof in a cafeteria duty was a goof I
used to cut that myself I got court I
got hollowed out by a vice-principal
because I was with McCrory at watching
football films downstairs I was supposed
to be on duty in the cafeteria
I was wouldn't Laguerre if I wonder if
he still smoking camels we had to call
me Hamill breath because he used to
smoke the camel red and his [ __ ] yard
George the camel McGrath his his his
beer his mustache was orange remember
mr. t from the [ __ ] camera big [ __ ]
Irish do wonder why but he used to be in
charge of driver ed he drive us up to
chance drag him in to get steak on a
stick
how [ __ ] cool was in joys the camera
grabbing man he used to have his fingers
were [ __ ] orange rightthey we used to
call him uh george megrath
we used to sing him that Def Leppard
song he lose his [ __ ] mind good guy
though him and mr. Zampella
Randy [ __ ] shave I bumped into ha
Tommy Knights in an Atlanta and I said
to him I was the disciple of Randy shave
and he just looked at me and shook his
[ __ ] head I
I hear that man see I was talking I
haven't started even telling these
[ __ ] Rago stories yet because I
don't think already I'm looking at a
picture of Rango right now all muscle
build it up this is before he passed in
99 this was we were always me and reg
over his [ __ ] bodyguards we didn't
give a [ __ ] and I talked to Joy ferrata
I talked to Joyce a lot of Monday he
called he's been listening to the church
what's his father were friends me and
Joey's father was yeah he went to bed
now that's right yeah he played from
Memorial long way and I placed him off
Bergen and we used to hang out together
at night poor and wasn't you know but
Rago was the best man he brings the
freshmen he broke his leg like before I
went to the hospital I stayed with him
in the hospital until his mother got
there that was like the me you never
forgot never forgot naughty we never
thought 18 30 years later I'm still on
the [ __ ] phone we all respect them so
I love you at all my heart and I'm happy
you call them you made my [ __ ] week
here
Shirley's [ __ ] I think's really
cracking in the Church of what's
happening now to you okay
hey we'll talk let me do my teeth give
them a method a method adieu hall and
company that's it man enderal one
company one time we're selling them on a
corner here from method ended rollin
company that's the label of your new
album man send it in 80 what was what
happened time what happened time you got
surrounded in Western yoke at the pool
by Puerto Ricans you said one dime one
phone call 24 to Ricans that's it man
that's what I said are you kidding me
that was like a [ __ ] scariest time of
my life over there but that was good we
get at it heaven that's it one time one
phone call
10,000 oh yes you see I love you I'll
call you there on the way god bless you
always and the boys and missus teasing
them all my love men and stay black t
that's the most important [ __ ] thing
you know
that's as good as it gets for me guys
that's Freddy Terranova my [ __ ]
teacher and he's on my wall and I'm
happy [ __ ] quality so musically
where's the [ __ ] music ahead what do
you want killing me a little [ __ ] in the
mama papa was a rollin stones by the
temptations let's put some [ __ ] soul
into their life before I send them onto
the [ __ ] world alright so that was
pretty crazy man it's a it's something
that I've learned hanging out with you
for a while is that your friends and
family I'm seeing you right now and
they're really important to you man haha
this is my life but I get a motion I'm
taking about uh you know all the times
went to school and and he'd be there you
didn't wanna [ __ ] be in school you
know and you go and he'd be there and
[ __ ] just make you laugh the only
reason when you went was because you
knew you didn't want to miss what mr. T
had to [ __ ] say you never wanted to
miss what you have to say you didn't
want to miss one of his jokes and you
know till this day man whenever I'm
having a bad week or whatever I'll give
him a call and just just two minutes on
the [ __ ] phone refuse me you know if
[ __ ] really does refuel be so uh that
that's basically it been the Church of
what's happened now is about getting you
out there and a [ __ ] good mood go out
there sling some dick you know what's
you know what I write yesterday I write
[ __ ] and I forget oh you said if you're
not gonna eat her [ __ ] why turn her
over
yeah why turn her over that's the [ __ ]
tomorrow they go out there wash your
[ __ ] balls listen man we all have bad
days who gives a [ __ ] I've been waking
up with no [ __ ] dough and having me
go to a diner in front breakfast like
eat in the front breakfast front
breakfast say listen I don't have money
to pay I forgot my wallet come back
tomorrow you know and then start your
day what you have nourish me you go out
there and [ __ ] rob so whatever the
[ __ ] it is that you do rob son stop you
know and if you can film whatever [ __ ]
you do you know so that's what we do
here is just get you stronger so you can
get out there and [ __ ] him sling dick
you understand me
cuz we all gonna walk into the [ __ ]
mouth l'Italia today we all [ __ ]
started - and it's all about just
getting on your [ __ ] horse and going
out there [ __ ] these [ __ ] they
can't stop you bro
I bumped into my main man Brody Stephens
DNA and we're at the Laugh Factory I'll
tell you about this no and I gave him a
big hug cuz I love Brody Stevenson all
my heart and I'm proud of him for his
show on HBO go and he looked at me at
one point he gotta go you know I'm
really proud and we're talking he looked
at me he knows what school of thought
I'm from he knows I'm gonna whole school
[ __ ] Jew from [ __ ] a long time ago
G cool dosed out you mix with I'm a Jew
that went to Catholic school that's what
the [ __ ] shows up with two guns
it don't get better than that I got the
best education I grew Santeria on top of
that I mix it with some Buddhism what I
got together is better than [ __ ] Jeet
Kune Do
so I look at Brody and you know bro
these gone through a lot the last couple
years looks at me with his [ __ ]
little piercing Jew eyes and he goes
don't stop keep going right
can I go dog I'm fat my mug Lee but I
got a big thing a lot of person now
ain't snap at me you know saying they'd
stopping us he's got a big thing a lot
of personality ain't gonna [ __ ] stop
you whether you have a big dick enough
we all got a big thing it's how you walk
on the street yeah it's how you perceive
yourself go out there you got the
10-foot [ __ ] dick when you walk down
the street you'll see if I mean nobody
will [ __ ] with you go out there people
too lazy or [ __ ] lucky they [ __ ]
it's not that little temptations they
get something to drink real quick what
do you got for me drop it on these
[ __ ] I'll be right back and
come back with listen to this [ __ ] you
know this is as good as it gets of my
[ __ ] eyes I'm gonna hate you were
rock music disco music [ __ ] knowledge
and now I'm gonna hit you with the core
these are [ __ ] five starving brothers
wherever the [ __ ] they were from Detroit
Michigan woman they were from all over
the south I love the [ __ ] patient's
this [ __ ] I'll be right back play it up
loud
you
girl great man this is great great
hey you migrate back huh there's my
little girl this is the last one I
brought up she was the I told you guys
she was the owners next door and she
would come by every night would call for
me she's my little sweet angel these
dogs these [ __ ] cats man when you
wake up in the morning I don't give a
[ __ ] what more do you make up in they
always put you in a better mood just
this just hugging them playing with her
nose getting get she gets pissed off
she don't like all this love she's a
little dirty [ __ ] but when you don't
give her love then she gets pissed right
beat it
[ __ ] what else dogs did you play
it already
yeah then so you turned it off I gotta
teach you how to [ __ ] play music
you're slipping with the music what the
[ __ ] a music on comes second you hook
them up it's like you gave my hand job
might they're gonna come you [ __ ] got
your hands off that [ __ ] to me you let
him go I tell you doesn't it killing me
but a little Weight Watchers breakfast
this morning I got my little Weight
Watchers power booklet right here see
you get 50 points and you're right down
all the [ __ ] points you know so I
used to eat like three eggs a half a
pack of [ __ ] bacon or loaf of [ __ ]
white bread the cup of [ __ ] hotel Bob
butter now I eat one egg one piece of
toast a little bit of butter and the
three or four pieces of Senate cuttin
Oscar Mayer [ __ ] bacon all total two
for the egg 2 for the piece of bread one
for the butter which is five about three
for the [ __ ] bacon eight point
breakfast his name bad Mike Dolce's a
little pissed off and make it sound like
the bowls and [ __ ] but I don't like no
vegetables in the [ __ ] morning I like
my vegetables later on I'll [ __ ]
smoke
what else is going on [ __ ] you're
sitting there you don't get me no music
you lower it on these [ __ ] people
look kick that [ __ ]
you
hello you to tell me that you what oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] here we go [ __ ]
your [ __ ] green red tea who you
thinking your [ __ ] deal with
[ __ ]
and we got no sponsors don't we tell
them we're looking for [ __ ] national
sponsor I don't know white ass will get
your [ __ ] together you [ __ ]
they get me on Twitter say that don't
want to [ __ ] sponsor me they want to
hang out and then I hit them back and
they're thinking about it they gotta go
talk to a white dudes with suits on it's
[ __ ] White Castle alright
one minute you eat a burger mix with
your [ __ ] blood get [ __ ] people
don't White Castle White Castle I grew
up on [ __ ] white cows you understand
it was the best establishment but it's
not for the [ __ ] food it's for the
ambience and entertainment world you
will get a burger three burgers for $1
he supported Rican gets that papa was a
rolling stone cut that [ __ ] Lee Lisa I
adhere the [ __ ] mastermind of this
[ __ ] organization the podcast
is getting download on iTunes it all hit
me no more with no [ __ ] questions
it'll be on iTunes and it's a good
podcast you're a problem you know I love
my level would you kill the [ __ ]
music music you know now we're gonna
talk about [ __ ]
I love these like they're bringing this
show Arrested Development back right
yeah now why'd they cancel the show it's
supposed to be the funniest oh my god
it's the funniest ring it's the
intelligence comedy listen do me a favor
you intelligent comics
go [ __ ] your [ __ ] mother up the ass
and intelligent comedy if it was so
subtle intelligent why did it stick
around now let's take a look at two
years to put the body show on the air
oh we got Ron Howard this guy's making a
comeback let's you suck my dick you
[ __ ] sheep he calmly [ __ ] fans if
it's not Arrested Development it's
[ __ ] Chuck
it's [ __ ] Conan you [ __ ] the
show blows they get cancelled make sure
you know you're jumping up and down on
Burbank save Coco the [ __ ] is
still nobody watching that [ __ ] show
I like Conan O'Brien Chuck I never watch
the [ __ ] show but again the Momo's
came up relay shut the [ __ ] I watch it
one time I'm gonna shot myself in the
[ __ ] head
from water and this Arrested Development
infamous don't [ __ ] funny what the
[ __ ] is it
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
you always want to be different to their
own because it's intelligent Connor you
put your little [ __ ] fake glasses on
and drink a little [ __ ] snippet of
wine at t what you suck my dick and get
on board and get on the real
[ __ ] world we stop being a
[ __ ] fake that's where the [ __ ]
country's gonna change Obama and Romney
and none of these mother fluffing is
gonna help you we don't help your
[ __ ] self so are you [ __ ]
with your iPhone and your iPad
the answer is I you know what you need
to [ __ ] do walking around with your
[ __ ] fake [ __ ] glasses on talking
about intelligent or Arrested
Development's making a second Ron Howard
Ron Howard's a great director
I never seen runnin out on stage [ __ ]
killing for ten [ __ ] minutes all right
for you all your mother [ __ ] well he's a
great comedic actor you know what the
difference is between comedic actors
what I do cut that's the [ __ ]
difference and take a cut and they could
do it again and you [ __ ] at
home John my god did you see him here
and I [ __ ] you with stand-up comics when
we go out there and then they no [ __ ]
directly no producer it's just us there
ain't no cut there ain't no do-overs you
go out there and you [ __ ] do it so
get your [ __ ] together on your judgement
Arrested Development you [ __ ] Momo's
they've been talking for you [ __ ] your
comedy oh [ __ ] your mother
intelligent common intelligence what you
make of it what good is if you're
[ __ ] intelligent but you waiting on
line and Starbucks in the morning with a
[ __ ] iPhone like a Momo for a cup of
coffee it's a [ __ ] cup of coffee they
got him at 7-eleven which is even
probably a lot better you drink
Brazilian Bolt no I mean it's like doing
meth in [ __ ] Tennessee okay you will
be up for two [ __ ] days drinking
Brazilian [ __ ] Bowl you think I'm
kidding you go to 7-eleven and get a cup
of coffee for a [ __ ] dollar go slow
ahead and do start your day off on the
right foot I'll see some sandals or some
[ __ ] I made the mistake of going to
Starbucks after the last podcast and
there were three guys behind there only
one guy was making the drinks and I
waited in line for 15 minutes for an
iced tea and I just halfway through it's
like I already made the decision you are
skin like a [ __ ] mobile like a sheep
like will you what your mother meant
raised you not to [ __ ] be first thing
your mom said to you before you left was
if three people jump off a cliff you
[ __ ] jump off a cliff I won half of
America to think about that [ __ ] every
[ __ ] morning are you gonna [ __ ]
jump off a cliff are you gonna put your
[ __ ] pants on with the two buttons in
the back and you're a guy and you tap
out shirt and look like every other
[ __ ] moment
oh you're gonna have your own [ __ ]
identity your own set of balls that's
why I write [ __ ] about balls every
morning because women and men have
[ __ ] balls turn that arrow
it's [ __ ] sweating I'm sweating up
the [ __ ] store Memorial Dwight you
know women when I write those things I'm
not writing them just for guys we all
have [ __ ] balls leave but they do you
no good if you're not doing nothing with
it yeah get up in the morning it's
[ __ ] early I'm gonna have my little
Weight Watchers breakfast you know I'm
saying I'm gonna write it down my book
looking looking looking great [ __ ]
the cap box right in front of me great
get your [ __ ] together over you look at
her taking a [ __ ] right here you know
I'm gonna do I'm gonna tie her up and
[ __ ] in [ __ ] face that old lady never
walked back down is blocking oh yeah she
couldn't that was a [ __ ] hilarious
tour I laugh just thinking about just
thinking about I told my wife the story
she couldn't [ __ ] believe I farted
outside gave a what a four minute four
second [ __ ] walk 30 seconds 30
seconds before she walked there and the
floor just elevated it was like it was
like David Copperfield it just stayed
right you got a love [ __ ] I love it I
love it
Oh Joey that's not intelligent comedy
where's Bill Maher and I love Bill Maher
no gay I love [ __ ] bill wanna watch
the show
Bill Maher put me on politically
incorrect long time as a mobster yeah
being Sebastian Maniscalco
oh he's funny man you have Sebastian's
real [ __ ] funny this is when
politically correct was stolen they had
mob week oh and then we're looking for
promos so me and Sebastian went down and
we got booked I remember taking
Sebastian my handler let's walk in there
these [ __ ] up my show was
hilarious oh yeah right this way did the
gene that he was waiting through the
genes right there Ross no he did one
that got released
Sebastian's a great kid representing
[ __ ] Chicago while you [ __ ]
that no no next week September 14th
me and Ari are going on presale in
Chicago two houses house lose that's
Chicago such a great gig police come out
and supports [ __ ] Chicago bring a hot
beef sandwich I love it
you have a hot beef Italian sale no
minuscule I have I haven't been to
Chicago but it seems like a place that I
would look up being from Boston I would
love it be from Boston being a [ __ ]
Jew all right let's get to the [ __ ]
being a good American [ __ ] Jew yeah
you need to be the [ __ ] Chicago it's a
great city
you know my love for Chicago is the
[ __ ] I love everything Southside
[ __ ] Northside hole-in-the-wall an
Italian place in the north side I like
downtown but my heart's in the side you
know me I'm a dirty [ __ ] yeah I believe
I belong in Tinley Park down there with
[ __ ] riddles and all those comedy
clubs down that love it you know if you
Bernie Mac all those guys are from then
you here's some [ __ ] great comedy
stories man they brave you're a comedian
and you love that [ __ ] you ever see
Sheryl Underwood pull her aside Cheryl's
on that show of morning show okay but uh
she was telling me some [ __ ] Chicago
stories when they'd all get in the car
for 50 bucks of [ __ ] like that so uh
Chicago's my heart man every time I go
oh my god they're nice when I used to go
to riddles there was a restaurant close
by an Italian restaurant I would call
them they would deliver a hot beef
sandwich and then the sandwich they'd
make a pipe for me out of aluminum foil
they put a little button there for me he
says he had a whole meal but till the
[ __ ] club started that's how cool the
[ __ ] guy was so I'm a big Chicago guy
I'm also next week I'm going to
Minneapolis to rick Bronson's house
economy I'll be a there from the 13
through the 16th I'm gonna have a great
time I don't know what the [ __ ]
number is but go to Rick Bronx is the
website I'm doing Thursday show I'm
doing Friday and Saturday week after
that I'm going to Madison Wisconsin
[ __ ] great town I'll go up there and
sling some [ __ ] dick and shoot to
[ __ ] gal who's a [ __ ] milky milk
house of comedy dotnet you can have the
okay and then yeah we got a Milwaukee
and Madison in there on my site that
brown paper tickets out we post them on
Twitter today
then I go to the [ __ ] one of the
baddest cities in the country and I'm
looking forward also to going to
Baltimore because that's the wire [ __ ]
oh he's saying that's the [ __ ]
why of [ __ ] I haven't been to
Baltimore in about 15 years
oh so you probably haven't been to
Camden yard that's a great baby kick oh
don't [ __ ] don't get me so that's a
great [ __ ] stadium in there in first
place now [ __ ] Baltimore the Yankees
are falling the Red Sox are falling
Baltimore's in the first we did with Jim
Lee apiece I didn't [ __ ] it man
that's a weight watcher breakfast right
there tell one of the people I hope let
me show them the value rub the belly all
right Oh Sofia look at my wife with the
miniskirt well piece of bacon Lee sir to
hell Joe hey buddy so now it even gets
it Lois this is it man this is it ma a
[ __ ] piece of ham one egg yolk
I don't like egg whites all right [ __ ]
you all
I [ __ ] hate egg whites with all my
heart open I why suck a dick and drink
the pre-cut that's and we're talking
earlier that's the thing I can't stand
people who eat healthy and they look Oh
salmon is great and boiled boiled
broccoli like you can eat healthy but it
doesn't have to be disgusting there
still can be good tasting food that's
why I like Weight Watchers y'all [ __ ]
food yeah so so you can eat the two eggs
and what will you have for lunch on it
like not a normal day I guess I'd like
to sell
this is my [ __ ] shoulder wash
yourself today I don't know I have much
of fruit law there for lunch today maybe
I don't know how maybe you get sushi
today
sushi is great but then it's I mean it's
a standard joke but I mean really yeah I
can get hungry like an hour later which
is tough I love sushi but it's anything
like that total of Reister and what I
don't know what it is but it gets you it
gets you earlier hungry later but I saw
something the other night which I don't
know if you'd like cuz it's all in
Japanese with subtitles the documentary
called jiro Dreams of Sushi it's about
this like 90 year old sushi set in Japan
who's been who got kicked out of his
house at the age of 9 and has been
apprentice and like the baddest sushi
chef in Japan he's like yes he is like
the highest rated sushi restaurant in
the country you're watching Lee and I
started going on the why I'm saying
doing jumping jacks your [ __ ] about a
sushi chef that's why I love you cuz
you're this thing was he fat no he's
skinny a [ __ ] I don't like skinny
chefs I don't trust me let me bring this
back
awesome musically for these people hit
him with some black sabot snowblind a
little song about cocaine and we'll wrap
this
for everyone else Jarrell's Dreams of
Sushi is a really good documentary
[Music]
[Music]
all [ __ ] Eliza little snow plan like
this [ __ ] always messes up the
lyrics like oh really
this one might be good what I sick those
within my bands cut that [ __ ] used to
drive me crazy I go home and whip out a
grandma blow and do it for this [ __ ] I
even line the [ __ ] cemetery some
laughter noodles Under the Sun I swear
to God when I was like a soft white
little cemetery with my boys
Diddy could tear we think like a half
gram little couple bumps listen to this
with a ghetto blaster how [ __ ] were
we this is bad
listen to this [ __ ] this is unfuck a
real
[ __ ] gaily weblink good time I'm having
people coming in you know stick them
calm let's give them a shout-out for
letting us on they're smoking dope
cursing talking about Obama's wife's
[ __ ] you know it's been unbelievable
the amount of love we've gotten on
Twitter and I've been getting emails
oh it's speaking of emails please send
us females and a church of what's
happening now pod and gmail.com we
already answered an email we'll answer
as many as we can any question you want
to ask Joey Joey Joey is really clear
breaking things down and it's we're
still looking for intro songs and I've
gotten a bunch of great ones already but
what we're looking for is like a rock
one with maybe Joey saying Church what's
happening now or we could record it here
but you know what kind of music Joe
studio yeah I could record it so we
could do ready yeah [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with joy bananas [ __ ]
but you know but like this Black Sabbath
is the stuff he likes and then and just
make it make it as rock as possible it's
the Church of what's happening that we
want to wake people up with this song
this is it you're going out into the
[ __ ] world I'm like your mother right
now I'm your mother I'm your daddy I'm
that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] alley I'm
saying I'm with you I'm with you all
[ __ ] day dawg [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
you're not alone no more and I walk the
[ __ ] steps you know saying I'm still
walking I married that's why I love walk
with me you [ __ ] maybe I'm gonna
put Bob we might do Bert Kreischer I'm
meeting the Beast today oh that's cool
saw Felicia last night please she's a
really great woman and she's a really
beautiful girl honest to god I'm really
lucky to have that crazy [ __ ] in my
life yes she's a [ __ ] animal
she really is a savage I didn't know
it's all about three [ __ ] months ago
how lucky I was
so keep listening to beating the beast
off so we're [ __ ] doing it although
covering we got an interview so we might
put bird on today because we had a
[ __ ] the guest fighter gonna come
home but he couldn't fly out he couldn't
make his [ __ ] flight so that's tough
person great guys the birds good on
podcast Bert listen man these podcasts I
had listened to a lot of them and I see
which guys are having struggling with
them because they can't be honest they
think this is [ __ ] radio the reason
why we do this cuz it ain't [ __ ]
radio so why are you treating it like
[ __ ] radio yeah you know why the
[ __ ] you treat it like radio fits
that radio get on there and tell these
[ __ ] people a true tell them what's
in your [ __ ] heart these people want
to go on their high and be [ __ ] radio
you ain't selling [ __ ] tell these
[ __ ] what's crack-a-lackin'
that's why I had tea out of this one I
got really emotional I talked to do you
have no idea where my heart my head was
that guy kept me [ __ ] alive that guy
kept myself early master surah it's
funny because Timmy Holloway I come from
Tim Ian Holloway yesterday he asked me
about for an embosser pseudo funny boss
a pseudo and I were a brothers Rago when
Cathy LeBron Oh Roger hallo these
[ __ ] guys are my brothers and and uh
the funny thing is really sad I was
there with Bernie when his daughter you
got a gun gambling oh he was the one who
bet on the I'm betting on the Super Bowl
right Super Ball he was up [ __ ] 20 he
ended up losing [ __ ] 60 right out of
high school nineteen eighty-three
thousand sixty thousand for being up
twenty thousand the beam down sixty what
a [ __ ] change and he had to get three
jobs never he never recovered from it
you know any [ __ ] turned into a
junkie they said whatever but he's
cooking somewhere in Hoboken I heard
he's a great chef and he hits me up on
my life from time to time who's on
[ __ ] my life they want to charge you
like 80 hours to join my life something
scam and yeah I think it's a scam they
always say for any basta pseudos looking
for you on my on whatever the [ __ ] it is
but I think it's [ __ ] but whatever I
T raised a bunch of us you know myself
that Rago we were there every day we'd
go to school looking for tea because God
forbid you missed what the guy had to
say god forbid you've seen somebody in
third period they're like dog you should
have heard what he said this morning
because you had different periods that
wasn't
mmm-hmm he took care of me in 85 no gets
[ __ ] 2012 I still talk to the guy
once a week he's in Sarasota so they
don't have that much now on this it's
really something special when you get a
teacher because like you said before
when you're a kid they spend like eighty
percent of time with [ __ ] percent of
time with you you know and now since all
these budget cuts is [ __ ] you get to low
end of the totem pole people that molest
kick listen when I went to school I
never heard of [ __ ] teachers a male
teacher assaulting a female and nothing
like that
yeah like I said the other day there was
a female teacher that was sucking
restless dicks that's a completely
different situation she like sweaty
balls and I said she likes smelly sweaty
balls I'm talking about you know people
molesting kids and that didn't happen my
[ __ ] society you know [ __ ] kill
you that's not accepted that's not even
something to think about you know this
shift that goes on now so you have a
certain trust of the [ __ ] teacher
how's he gonna be following your dick
and don't get me wrong you know by the
time we are high school we're party with
these [ __ ] and he was talking
about the graph the camel breath you
know George the graph camel breath sold
blow for a guy helped him out that they
had to make deliveries and you couldn't
you know you're white you can't have a
[ __ ] Colombian kid coming over here
so he'd be the white guy he delivered
the white people for this guy you don't
even have parties and [ __ ]
as a teacher delivering coke okay fine
you like to make a [ __ ] living you
know I mean this is this was that area
this is 1980 in Hudson County [ __ ]
New Jersey this is the second you know
the coke comes in goes into Miami from
Miami we go to Hudson [ __ ] County
it's Cuba [ __ ] Ville yeah yeah
doesn't happen now with Facebook and
said I would get out in two seconds well
it wasn't that he wasn't selling it to
kids he was doing it outside in New York
City so the guy he was working for was
in New York City
he would have to go to New York you know
white guys having a charity you know you
know those people they were your 50,000
but they want everybody in the world to
know oh my god you know they call
somebody in McGrath would [ __ ] come
bring a [ __ ] package that's what I'm
talking about okay wasn't like some guy
at a bar no he was delivering it to
white people people Republicans you know
people got done living the [ __ ] Upper
West Side Upper East Side you know
and he got it to sell it for a while
afterward he was because what happened
was we robbed that the story goes like
this we robbed a coke dealer
two weeks after the guy he was the guy
that beat us for the Ozzy Osbourne
tickets okay when I went over there he
goes no the coke is really 128th grandma
like you've been charging the 60 the
whole [ __ ] time his name is Mike and
I went in there we robbed them for a
half ounce of [ __ ] blow and that
Sunday we had ferny in the cars summer
school you if you had three absences
they would throw you on a Sunday school
Wow so [ __ ] ferny I had two or three
out to have two absences we were up all
night doing blow so we had to go to T's
house and tell T if he could cover for
him in summer school this is the kind is
how we had it and I'ma be knocking on
his door seven more than T's like his
wife goes oh my god cocoa fruity how
good to see you she's like I'll get
Freddie and Wilson he comes over he's
like look at these [ __ ] guys so why
he get he's like go outside and wait for
us you know so it's me fir in this kick
Conti sitting in the [ __ ] car and
we'll send uh downstairs from T there
was a teacher named Jerry compassed Oh a
real Greek geeky [ __ ] good-good
guy and he would drive for Freddie the
school and mr. T came down the stairs
and he's like what's going on here we
showed him to 1/2 ounce of [ __ ] blow
in a tin and he went crazy is like he
was time to teach you two minutes and
finally when we show him the Tabasco
leave without being he drove with us and
I thought we were gonna burn up and done
and if--and they gave my grandma blow a
week later I had to go collect the money
and I want any goes go to george megrath
when I went to George George goes of
course he dead of course he snorts and I
pay you know so he goes you thought that
was good [ __ ] you gave me and I go yeah
he works out a [ __ ] bag out of his
freezer
it had to be two [ __ ] kilos and he
goes try this so for weeks I was
fronting from mr McGrath fretting going
over they go grab give me an Etoile Joey
you owe me $2,000 when is this gonna end
you know what does it mean I'll go put
on the other you got my arms are heavy
my arms are [ __ ] heavy Coco I don't
like putting on glasses I feel like that
[ __ ]
dude for whatever but uh it was funny
because I always was friends with
McGrath after that I was friends with
tea and stuff and the other day we had
Looby on ruby was talking about Robby
has a gas station we robbed the hassle
of time and the funny thing about the
Hess was that we robbed something and it
was a big bag we'll we looked at each
other like were rich we get in the
[ __ ] car
we open it up and it's filled with
singles oh Jesus you look like eight
million dollars but it was Baal singles
and I remember getting three hundred
singles together for George we graph
like call him and go on a three in the
one mr McGrath going down the shore
front me give me an April him gone no no
no no no no you owe too much already
Coco and I go I got cash he goes I see
on the corner three minutes that's
really how the conversation was and I
met him at this bag three hours look
like world's bags with cartoons that
have the money sign Oh unbelievable
it was this [ __ ] big and he looked at
he's like thank God you pay me the money
you owe me
but an hour later I called my everything
all right he goes 300 [ __ ] singles
three hundred [ __ ] single I got this
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] that was McGrath
is on [ __ ] Facebook you won't front
he won't be buddy but that's a shirt for
you you gonna be my friend on Facebook
forty on your agenda today leaked what
are you gonna do today it's a beautiful
Wednesday day it's a beautiful day I'm
gonna try to work out before I go to
work man they're talking all right so
I'll be around so maybe we'll work out
together I'll be here absolutely little
why again today I do something a lot
much on the books today but I'm happy
you came over and happy [ __ ] mr. T
cause I'm happy we got to do our fourth
[ __ ] podcast it'll be up later this
week yeah by tomorrow
it's amazing talking to the people you
talk to and I'm you we all heard stories
about them but it's hearing them on the
phone he was and when I was thought it
was gonna sound like I can just I can
just imagine him in Sarasota Florida
right now just walking around with white
socks on and long skinny legs telling
people go on with your bad self
yeah like the oyes all the [ __ ] OJ's
cuz that's jalapenos oh yeah oh yeah
come on Tom they only say oh yeah so he
we came with different
he's like the fluffy oh yeah ah it's
really made it shows where you've got
your comedy from every everyone will
personally talk to it's like a little
piece of dough ideas nah he's he was my
one of my biggest [ __ ] mentis and
that's it brother what are we coming
back I'm gonna be doing another podcast
do you want to do one Monday or would
you underwent for one [ __ ] Monday
perfect oh my baby will go do one before
church again we don't know okay on a
Sunday cuz last Sunday was [ __ ] up
we'll have to take him to little bleep
thank you very much for helping me and
all that you've done for me I want to
thank everybody who watched I want to
thank everybody who [ __ ] download
this [ __ ] also also we did not
discuss it it is the season premiere of
NFL football this weekend but I have no
whines I can't I have to watch a few
games and then we'll make you guys some
money because I'm gonna make you money
[ __ ] watch the show trust me won't
tell you Lito you know it's tough link
it to the hoop I would come work with
Joe everybody here and he would call me
every Sunday morning call me but every
day just to check in and he would call
me on Sunday morning and say what are
you looking at now I know his pilot the
Patriots and he would break down he's
like who's playing today who's playing
today
you bring like the Browns he break down
every game and he would it would be like
with the Browns and Cincinnati which no
one wants to watch but he but these are
that's where you put your money that's
where you put your money why I bet the
games that we have a [ __ ] Bob wolf
watching be [ __ ] unique be yourself
bro that's all that [ __ ] matters
don't forget Minnesota next week
Wisconsin Milwaukee and Madison and then
we got [ __ ] Walter more beside that
go to Joey couple Diaz dotnet we got
don't eat blue cheese shirts we got stay
black shirts
jr. I send them to Australia to England
he don't give a [ __ ] Junior as my little
black brother up there and [ __ ]
Rochester New York junior production
still between he's a [ __ ] savagely I
love you [ __ ] I have a great week
I want to hereby you're working on your
diet when you get back you gotta go -
wait wait watching you can eat whatever
the [ __ ] you want you know instead of 20
pieces of chicken you could
in the south yeah we'll talk about it
Monday I love you guys thank you very
much for paying attention and for
watching and stay black sticky stick I'm
calm
get it together [ __ ] on watch it
you know I love you there's some Black
Sabbath war pigs go on to the world on
that [ __ ] note [ __ ] this Jew
is making a comeback today
you
[Music]